اذا مشاهدينا الكرام اليوم السابع من
المعارك داخل السودان يوم عنيف للغايه وفق
ما افادى به مراسلونا نبدا بدايه وطبيعه
الحال كانت الخرطوم العاصمه هي التي شهدت
اهم وابرز هذه المعارك وسجالات السيطره
بين الطرفين عندما نتحدث عن الخرطوم فنحن
نتحدث عن وسط البلاد والعمليات العسكريه
في الخرطوم تركزت بشكل اساسي في المنطقه
الجنوبيه من النيل الازرق ونتحدث تحديدا
عن هذا المربع او المستطيل او الدائره او
هذا المثلث الذي يمتد بهذا الشكل المنطقه
الجنوبيه من الخرطوم كانت الاعنف اليوم مع
العمليات العسكريه التي نفذها الجيش
السوداني الذي يقول في هذه الصوره الاقرب
بان قوته تقدمت بشكل اساسي في المنطقه
الجنوبيه وانها تحاول استعاده السيطره على
المناطق الجنوبيه على هذا الخط الذي بين
النيلين من النيل الابيض الى النيل الازرق
وبالعكس على مسافه تمتد الى حوالي عشره
كيلو متر تقريبا وتشمل احياء مهمه هي
المدينه الرياضيه والصحافات وجبر هذه هذا
الخط الذي يمتد بين نيلين كما ذكرنا يضغط
الجيش السوداني بشكل كبير باتجاه المناطق
الشماليه حيث تدور المعارك وفق التقارير
الاوليه في هذه المحاور مع التقارير
المقابله بان هذه المنطقه الشماليه كانت
هادئه نسبيا وهي منطقه المطار والقصر
الجمهوري ومقر قياده العمليات او القياده
العامه للجيش السوداني مع الحديث عن بعض
اصوات اطلاق نار في هذه المنطقه ولكن بشكل
عام المنطقه الشماليه من من الخرطوم كانت
هادئه نسبيا مقارنه بالايام الماضيه حيث
شهدت هذه المنطقه وهي المنطقه التي نتحدث
عنها مقر قياده الجيش ومطار الخرطوم
والقصر الجمهوري شاهدت عمليات ولكن الجيش
الان يقول انه بسط سيطرته بشكل كبير ولكن
هناك بعض التقارير تفيد باطلاق نار بين
الحين والاخر في هذه المنطقه المهمه
للغايه منطقه القصر الجمهوريه ومقر قياده
الجيش او قياده عمل القوات المسلحه اذا ما
عدنا للخريطه السابقه الخريطه اليوم خلال
الساعات القليله الماضيه كما ذكرنا
العمليات العسكريه تركزت في المنطقه
الجنوبيه وتحديدا ايضا شارع ستين الذي
يمتد من الجنوب الى الشمال هذا الشارع مهم
للغايه لانه يربط المناطق الشماليه
بالمناطق الجنوبيه شهده توترا واقتنع
عنيفا وايضا كان هناك شارع مهم اليوم برز
اسمه وهو يمتد من شارع 60 وينزل جنوبا هو
شارع مدني اذا تحدثنا عن شارع مدني فهناك
نقطه غايه في الاهميه وهي الحديث عن سيطره
لقوات الدعم السريع على منطقه المسعوديه
او بالتحديد على مصنع في منطقه المسعوديه
لماذا نتحدث عن اهميه هذه النقطه لان شارع
مدني هذا الشارع الذي يمتد
العاصمه الخرطوم باتجاه الجنوب يمر من
منطقه المسعوديه على بعد حوالي 50 كيلو
متر عن وسط العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
اهميه المسعوديه بانه اذا ما تمت السيطره
على شارع مدني وقطعت خطوط الامداد في هذه
المنطقه فيعني ان كل الامدادات القادمه من
المنطقه الجنوبيه ومن منطقه الجنوبيه
الشرقيه على شارع مدني وبالتالي الى
المدينه الى وسط العاصمه ستتوقف اما ان
هذه الامدادات قادمه بالدعم السريع
وبالتالي وجود الدعم السريع في هذه النقطه
سيعزز هذه الامدادات ويسهل تقدمها نحو
العاصمه وان كانت الامدادات قادمه من
الجيش من الجهه الجنوبيه فهو سيطره الدعم
السريع على هذه النقطه سيعطل وسيقطع
امدادات الجيش باتجاه المنطقه الشماليه
والعاصمه لانه هناك حديث مهم للغايه الان
عن الامدادات القادمه من المناطق الخارجيه
خارج العاصمه وتحديدا المناطق الجنوبيه من
القطارف والجزيره الجزيره تحديدا تعتبر هي
الحاضنه الجنوبيه للعاصمه وبالتالي الدعم
العسكري القادم من ولايه الجزيره الى
ولايه الخرطوم العاصمه دعم مهم للغايه
لذلك يكون السيطره على شارع مدني او قطع
شارع مدني هو قطع سيفصل هذه المعادله او
سيكون له ما بعده اذا ما تحدثنا عن شارع
مدني بدرجه اساسيه هذا الشارع الذي نشاهده
الذي يمتد من المنطقه الجنوبيه الى الشمال
السيطره على هذا الشارع ستعني قطع خطوط
الامداد الان الحديث يدور عن عوده اصوات
اطلاق النار قبل قليل في مناطق مختلفه في
محيط
قصر الجمهوري والقياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه وايضا في مدينه ام درمان الى
الشمال الجزء المهم من العاصمه الخرطوم
هاتان المنطقتان تشهدان الان اصوات اطلاق
نار رغم ما اعلن من جانب الجيش عن هدنه
لمده ثلاث ايام حتى لحظه الهدنه لم تثبت
بشكل اساسي وبشكل نهائي ليكون المشهد
الميداني اليوم السابع للمعارك في الخرطوم
او في السودان بشكل عام يتركز العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم وتحديدا المناطق
الجنوبيه المدينه الرياضيه جبرا الذي يقول
الجيش السوداني انه ينفذ عمليات تمشيط
واسعه النطاق في هذه الاحياء سعيا نحو
تمشيط هذه المنطقه بالكامل واخلائها من
قوات الدعم السريع